[Music]
one of the reasons I wanted to interview
you is because you were asked the
question could you beat me in a fight
and I wondered if you prepared to put
your money where your mouth is why don't
we make a bet I bet you 50 Grand you
take the 50 Grand bet 50 Grand I look
forward to kicking your ass
Rob Moore you're a very successful
person you've got a training company I
think you're the second biggest in the
UK I think the first you know we're the
first definitely not let it slide that
you say you're the larger yeah well that
is a stupid thing to say
why did you kick me out your event
you've been in Disguise now I got kicked
out you threw me at you again when you
first saw my face on a billboard and it
just happened to be in your hometown 30
dick move and 70 smart move I would say
disruptive though right yeah disruptive
who do you think is more disruptive out
of me and you
I think you're louder
it's absolutely false to say rich people
don't pay tax it's not true I've spent
17 years of my life showing people that
there's another way and that way is to
be an entrepreneur yeah I have a lot of
haters you could fill Manchester United
football stadium with my Hayes I should
love all my haters they're helping me go
viral how much would you sell your
property company to me right now I'll
tell you to get in your Range Rover and
[__] off
Rob Moore Samuel ladies good to have you
on the Samuel Lee's Channel great to be
here first question is what made you
agree to come and sit down with me and
be interviewed on the channel today
we've been in the same industry a long
time and never really done any public
content together you're one of the
disruptors I would say and I always like
to get to know the person you know you
and I know each other a bit
but spending a few hours together we get
to know each other properly yeah and I
think you know you're predominantly
known as a property investor you're also
a businessman you're an influencer
you've got podcasts one of the reasons I
wanted to interview you is because you
said on an interview you were asked the
question could you beat me in a fight
and you implied that you think you could
take me on a fight and I wondered if
you'd be prepared to put your money
where your mouth is I wouldn't say
anything unless I was prepared to put my
money when the map is so are you calling
me out asking me for a fight yeah
exactly that okay would you fight me yes
I expect yeah wow okay well give it to
our team and see if we can get the
contracts drawn up that's all good well
um why don't we make a bet I bet you 50
Grand functional MMA you choose
boxing boxing all right 50 Grand you
take the 50 Grand bet yeah
we're going to make it happen yeah man
you've called me out for a fight yeah
man I accept 50 Grand I look forward to
kicking your ass you're a very
successful person you've got a training
company
um one of the biggest I think you're the
second biggest in the UK I think the
first I think you first yeah um you know
we're the first well I I how do you
define big um well Revenue I suppose is
one measure amount of people is that
because your courses are so much more
expensive than mine now no no a lot of
ours are under two grand most of our
courses are under two grand how much are
your courses generally if I wanted to do
all your courses if I was almost gonna
do I love Progressive I love Rob I've
been doing everything well I mean I have
membership site course podcast course
have public speaking course uh property
investing course commercial conversion
course rent to rent course no money down
course benefited deal packaging course
like if you wanted to buy about a whole
lot I just bought everything
individually that one then that one and
that one and that one did everything
so every single course let's say there's
15 let's say the average is is there two
let's say you either you're saying well
when you get to a certain size yeah you
can't keep count can you I asked you how
many properties you've got and you
didn't I told you I've done about 100.
you didn't say over 100 yeah and I
talked about it depends how that's it's
actually so over 100 isn't a specific
number just like about 15 isn't a
specific number if I could go upstairs
and find out all right oh look so about
15 and I listed about 10 of them there
yeah so let's say they're on average two
grand each including the Vats yeah so 30
grand for the lot but you go to
university for five years you're nearly
100 Grand in debt for what you can't
make any money yeah I've made many
millions hundreds of millions when you
had the training course and the
properties together Revenue yeah profit
but revenue is hundreds of millions yeah
I went to architecture degree did three
years came back with 50 Grands worth of
debt and [__] nothing never used it
again so I believe 30 grand for 15
courses is better than the better the
University degree I did anyway I would
agree with that do your courses come
with mentoring and we have separate
mentoring programs yes so there's
support for the um the courses but
mentoring is very different as you know
you know there's education and
implementation and I sort of separate
those someone hasn't got educated what's
the point in mentoring them if they've
not got the basic skills they need the
basic skills so we do education and then
implementation because just
conversely there's a lot of people who
are well educated and don't do anything
it's true so yeah so we did mentoring so
you do the courses dirty Grand if you do
all of them if you do all of them I mean
those people start with one or two yeah
all right maybe three or four buy to let
and how much is your mentoring then
um well it depends yeah it depends
um if you have a group mentoring it
might be five grand a year so what about
if you want one-on-one with you on
one-on-one with me well it's sold out
right now and I probably have turned
four dozen people away in the last nine
months but I had about 50 clients they
all pay 40 000 pounds plus that 40 Grand
and how long does that last well it
lasts a year but they basically have me
forever they've got my WhatsApp so 40
Grand and then you've got mentoring from
Rob Moore well it's one year but they'll
never kick them out after a year and go
sorry
um and they get to like meet you and
stuff and do one-on-one oh yeah we do
one-on-ones face-to-face groups they
come to my events they've got my mobile
phone number they WhatsApp me a lot I've
had clients that paid me by the way it
when I started 17 years ago yeah it was
two grand sure it's not just inflation
because inflation is not as much as that
it's also I've got 360 properties 1250
tenants have just done a 20 20 million
development
small price to pay to buy that knowledge
I agree and I think you're right about
University people will happily spend 30
grand going to University to get a
degree in Sports Therapy which might
give them a job that makes them 30 grand
a year yeah but they would never want to
invest 30 grand to learn from actually
someone that's making millions of pounds
and normally it takes people a few years
they don't I mean I know you'd probably
go I laughed a lot 30 grand I'll just go
for it Quantum Leap but most of my
students they do it over a few years so
they can do it bit by bit based on their
affordability when I came to one of your
events my only experience because people
ask me about Progressive property and
how is it what's it like and of course
I've not been I know you've been you've
been in Disguise now I got kicked out
you yeah but you had to go in to get
kicked out why did you kick me out your
event I didn't because I wasn't there
because why did your company kick me out
um one because they didn't understand
why you were in Disguise so they thought
what Samuel leads who is an up and
coming competitor to us what's he doing
until he had a microphone on and you
were recording it and we didn't know at
that time you were doing your Financial
Freedom challenge so I think it's
probably you know you don't want to take
a risk do you win what do you think
afterwards though when when you knew I
was doing a Financial Freedom challenge
did you feel a bit bad or did you were
you annoyed with me for coming or what
did you think now I wasn't annoyed with
you for coming because mate when I
started my property training company 17
years ago I went to all the other events
because I want to learn I didn't have to
go into disguise because I wasn't known
so how could I be pissed off at you for
doing something that I did 16 17. why
did you text me though when you saw when
you first saw my face on a billboard and
it just happened to be in your hometown
why did why did you text me like saying
what's this about what's happening well
I mean it wasn't what's this about it
was I wanted to understand why you were
doing it
um yeah because I thought
okay Samuel Leeds doesn't need to do
property events in Peterborough we're
the only training company in
Peterborough we're the we're the big one
that everyone targets
um so
he's either like staking his claim that
is coming for us or he's got more
[__] money than censor on him
billboard ads in Peterborough
um
and yeah so I wanted to know why you did
it but I didn't know if I'd get the
truth but I think I did just get the
truth because you told me before and I
believe you
um I thought it's quite a good move it
was 30 dick move and 70 smart move I
would say disruptive though right yeah
disruptive I mean because you know if
you went and did that to 10 of the big
competitors in your industry you know a
few of them would get really [__] off
you know I didn't I didn't get [__]
off did you didn't you know never go at
you no no not at all and I haven't done
that in Birmingham no but Birmingham was
not my patch no well she's we're like
Nationwide so yeah you know where's your
office based
um London yeah yeah all right I'm gonna
find the address
field yeah what what drives you Rob
you've got you've got a big business of
course you don't have to be a trainer a
lot of people that start out doing
training in fact do you think there's do
you think there's too many property
trainers
um it's difficult to say so are there
too many property trainers
um I think that too many people
start training
when they haven't yet earned the stripes
right and you know if you're a doctor
you've got to spend seven years plus
earning your stripes you don't go on
module one and say there's the knife go
cut yeah and some people
they teach too soon before they've
earned their stripes I've done 50
property deals before I even talked
about it and when I talked about it I
wrote a book yeah you know so some
people now they've got a couple of
properties in there running a training
business but then you and I and
entrepreneurs and you can't blame them
for being entrepreneurial
um I actually think there's less now I
think pre-lockdown there was a lot and
you made the running joke that I trained
most of them so I've kind of got myself
to blame because a lot of them have been
trainers of ours but now I think it's a
lot less now yeah I think I've got wiped
out because you were running courses on
how to set up a property training
company I think no no I would train
people to be Trainers for me I didn't
have a course on how to set up a
training yeah company but I had internal
training where I would train trainers
through now the reason I did it is
because I realized I had a year let's
say it's 2000
12 13.
I did 250 speaking days and when I do a
speaking day it's not a 30 minute
keynote speech pay me my fee and mwah
it's like eight nine hours of Hardcore
training you know what I started running
master classes and all the questions at
the end and you go for the dinner it can
be 10 hours straight I did 250 days of
those and I was [__] yeah I also broke
the world record for the longest speech
in that year and you know I loved it but
I was [__]
and then also I thought
well if I want to double the turnover
this training company have I got to do
500 speaking days a year I can't and so
I realized I was the bottleneck to my
own business and I was the limit of the
growth so I started bringing the
students through I always brought
students through and I hired
salesman they had to have done training
with me be a student turned trainer and
I started to train them and now I mean
we out our highest year we did 850
training days it's 2.5 a year and I
probably did 20 of those and I'm really
proud that I've been able to do that and
that's also a hard thing to do in
business isn't it remove yourself and
let the business scale up without you so
yeah and a few of them are set up in
competition and some of them are my
content and some of them piss me off and
some of them and you know maybe a couple
of them maybe not so credible but most
of them good and load's still loyal to
us what do you think of Paul Smith
what the fashion designer
touchdown what I think of Paul Smith
Touchstone
um so he was one of our students and he
got results
um
learning from us I remember mentoring
him and
he was an implementer I remember he came
with a lot of ideas and I guided him
around some of the a lot of the ideas he
came with I thought it was probably not
going to work I'm always really with my
mentees
if I don't think it's going to work I'm
going to tell him straight I'm not going
to oh yeah you'll be great positive
thinking you know I'm like I don't think
that business would all work I think
it's stupid don't do it because I think
it's really important you don't pay for
mentoring to get told what you already
know you pay for mentoring to get to
what you don't know so it come with all
these various different ways to make
money and ideas and I'll be like I don't
think you should do that don't think you
should do that and sometimes you'd
listen to me and sometimes it wouldn't
and he's like look rob you know I always
want to work with you I don't want to
never want to set up a training business
must I said in 158 times
um and actually
um he was doing service accommodation
and doing it quite well and we didn't
have that in our repertoire of training
courses and as far as I'm concerned if
there's a way to make money in property
I wouldn't either make money in it find
someone who's making money in it and if
it's legitimate why would I not teach it
to others
um I've got training business as well as
a property portfolio and um
we we went the first to teach service
accommodation but we were the first to
make it big in this country
um and
then he left and set up Touchstone
and like look at the building he
probably rented
looks the [__] same as ours but with
a different logo look at the inside it
looks the same as ours but with a
different logo
um and I actually see that as a real
compliment you know when people rip us
off and go and set up on their own
because one we've given him the platform
I can't blame him for going setting up
his own training business because I
start my own training business when I
was I was working for a property
Trading Company we were doing deals and
then I set up Progressive property in
2007. probably borrowed some of the
ideas of them so
you know not
that's what happens do you think he did
rip you off though well
I think he copied a lot of our content
I'm sure he copied other people too
um is some of it a bit too similar for
my liking yes but he learned from us you
know if you learn Jiu Jitsu from the
Gracie Masters and you became a master
you'd probably have traits like them
you'd probably fight like them so that
doesn't really bother me
um there's some stuff that went on
behind the scenes a deal went wrong he
took us he took clients money I've never
done that I've never taken clients money
in a deal gone wrong I've never gone
bust I've never lost any money in deals
or loans ever and I'm really proud of
that and I try [__] hard
to hustle when things go wrong we had
200 tenant 99 apartment block
halfway through development in the
lockdown lockdown [__] you know
um but we put 4.4 million of our own
money in but we had a 12 million
development loan but we we hustled and
we got through yeah and I know a deal
went South with him and he should have
hustled more and he should have not just
um you know shut the company down and
um you know all the investors just lost
their money that shouldn't have happened
because when Paul when Paul left he
would just leave you know he said you're
a liar didn't they uh he said all sorts
of [__] I I don't know what he said
because I don't I didn't study and watch
and read him yeah he said all sorts of
[__] yeah but I'm not the only one who
said he says it about am I
I don't know I don't really follow him
too much but I thought it was just
interesting what he was saying I'm sure
it wasn't true but why do you think he
was so disgruntled why did you think he
turned so I don't think he was
disgruntled I got no sense of
disgruntlement in fact I I would imagine
he's probably quite grateful
um of what we taught him and now he runs
a training business and assuming that's
successful which he makes it look like
from the outside well I didn't get that
he was disgruntled or just yeah I just
think that's his style I just think he's
quite combative yeah and aggressive I
think that's that's how some people are
that's how they we were talking off
camera about some people who their
marketing all they really know how to do
is attack the others yeah and I'm not
saying he directly did that but I think
he's he's competitive as an individual
yeah yeah you've got a lot of businesses
you've got a letting agency development
investment training which one would you
say brings you the most stress or is the
hardest to run
um probably the training business yeah
so I think some people who've bought a
few properties look at the training
business oh that's easy you do a seminar
and you sell two grand courses I'll be a
millionaire
I mean you know we've got very regularly
1.1 million overhead a month
sometimes 1.2 million as in every month
you haven't just spent a million just to
pay for the venues the staff the
buildings yeah yeah the marketing
um it can vary because it depends how
much you spend on outside of spend
between 120 and 300 a month Grand a
month on ads so that depends and you
know you expand a contract like with
lockdown we did
slightly retract not majorly and we cut
costs but yeah
um you know having for someone like me
who had no money had no inheritance
started a business from scratch having
1.2 million a month
overhead
you know at times that came out in fact
that's a lot of responsibility oh yeah
we employ more than 144 stuff I know
because last time I counted it was 144
of which there were just over 100 in the
office you haven't been upstairs yet but
one of our main offices up there are
letting agencies there and about 40 yard
outsources it might be 152 now something
like that and yeah at times I'm like
but actually now I love the
responsibility
um I think that the lean mindset is
really important stay hungry every day
every week every month stay hungry
and having that overhead keeps me hungry
yeah um so I would say the training
business actually is probably more
stressed now we have 1250 tenants but my
letting agency manages them and I don't
I've not spoke to a tenant in 16 years
um so that might be more stressful for
my business partner or my letting agency
dealing with 1250 tenants but I don't
deal with that personally yeah and in
terms of you know my brand like yours
has done really well that makes me good
money and that's the fun part yeah
chatting about what you do
um so yeah the training business is I
mean I'm not really that operationally
involved but I'm very strategically
involved and I do live and breathe it I
think when I started doing training one
of my mentors told me not to do it in
fact my brother Russell who's now my
business partner said to me don't do
that that's a that's a terrible idea
you're going to have
um loads of haters you're gonna have
legal problems you're going to be
enslaved people are buying a course
they're not buying anything actual
tangible so if they don't get results
they're going to blame you it's going to
be a really difficult business and um I
disagreed with him and start trying to
visit us up anyway and he was right
but you still do it I still do it
because it's it's a mission for me more
than anything as well and yes sure we
you know people invest but it is
something that I'm doing because I'm
passionate about it sometimes I think oh
Jesus should I even bother
um but what is it that drives you to to
run you know your training business what
is it there well
I didn't really do anything that well I
did a few sports but I was never going
to be a professional Sportsman I could
draw but was never going to be an artist
so the first thing I actually did really
well and actually made good money from
was property so surely it makes sense
then that that would be a business that
I would create multiple streams of
income from
um I think it might have been Robert
Allen's book way back in the day and
multiple streams of income
um but I remember reading about
you know you need multiple streams of
income for diversification for security
for risk obviously for scale
and so I started buying buy to lets
bought about 20 in our first year about
30 in our second year kept some traded
some
and then I realized okay you know we've
got a portfolio here
but you know if the market turns or
um we have issues with the property
manager at the time that could be a bit
of a risk so I need to create extra
income streams so maybe you can get
Insurance commissions you write a book I
wrote a book in 2008 called property
investor secrets and you know then we
people are like oh I want more than a
book I want to know what you know and
you my first course I only had 25 people
in it you know we have events now with
hundreds of people but my first one was
just intimate with 25 people me teaching
how we bought 70 properties in the first
two and a half years or whatever
um but I really do believe
that it's important that you build
multiple streams of income
and so
um that's why I built the training
business because it was an extra income
stream and it was the only thing in my
life I'd done and done well and made
really good money out of it so I felt
really credible to tell other people and
if everyone's asking you anyway well you
might as well set up a business the best
way to stop all the people dming you and
asking for your time for free and
getting overwhelmed just say buy my two
grand course and you know at the start
that was kind of why I did it I didn't
think would be the biggest property
training company in the UK in no time at
all I just thought well I can't handle
all this incoming I'm gonna do a course
all right buy it and then they bought it
yeah yeah how um how many students do
you have coming to events a month I
don't know
I don't know I know that because the
thing is like our courses I don't maybe
you make more money or generate more
Revenue because you've got so many
different courses and mentorships and
stuff
as they're a lot less we've only
basically got two products with uh two
grand courses and then our Academy which
is mentoring and everything and how much
is that one that one's twelve thousand
yeah and that's like the top end of me
personally mentoring
um and that's what we have but we have
like 3 000 people a month coming to the
training program so I guess it depends
on how you define the largest but I
would definitely not let it slide that
you say you're the larger yeah well
I suppose you could argue
not seeing the numbers but you know you
could argue that you know you have one
vertical and that might bring more
people through a month and I think it's
a irrelevant argument to say we have
more courses and I told you what our
Revenue was and I know you know that's
big numbers in our industry
tens of thousands of people a year I
don't have the number on it I told you
we did 850 training days
think that might have been 2019 yeah I
mean we've got a training Suite over
there with four training rooms in it
upstairs we can get about 250 in and
we've got other Master classrooms for
sort of 35 or 40 and that's full every
day two three or four four of the rooms
I mean and don't forget I've been doing
this 16 years I've had Progressive
property so when you add all that up
yeah millions of people have been in
some way introducing no respect you know
respect for what you're doing and what
you've done who runs most of the
training now then now you've sort of
stepped back a little bit Yeah so um
Kevin McDonald yeah Kevin paneskis
um is Kevin the one that kicked me out
of the event
maybe he's a he's a little balding Irish
guy full of energy yeah and I think I
could imagine he probably quite enjoyed
kicking you out probably yeah so tell me
then Rob like in the property industry
every few years things change don't they
the market changes what do you think now
in 2023 with all of the taxes the
legislation what do you think the best
strategies are to do right now in this
market in property yeah right well the
first answer is it depends on your area
because local councils have diff as you
know have very different planning rules
you know if you go to Oxford versus
Peterborough you know that's very
different we don't do listed or anything
like that and so in our city and
Peterborough just outside London
um what's worked really well for the
last five years is converting commercial
usually retail with space above
into residential so commercial to
residential conversion we started with
lots of single lets then we did
multi-lets then we did developments and
now we do conversion projects so we've
got one in the center of town on Bridge
Street old marks and Spencer's building
135 000 square foot we developed up a
couple of floors on the wings
and that's got 200 tenants 99 Apartments
we paid 4.4 all in plus bits
um probably about 12 million development
loan maybe a bit less I'd have to check
on Mark on the numbers
um and that's worth about 20 million
which you pick that up and put that in
Kensington and Chelsea and it's 200
million and we've made really good money
on that it's got good Equity it's got
really good rent roll
um and that works really well in our
city because there's massive housing
demand there's not enough
um read sorry
not enough flats and houses and
residential I mean there's not in the
whole country but but in our Center and
there's the right kind of buildings for
development you know this High Street
that's been decimated all this dead
space above
but if I was just starting out I would
never do that yeah because that's way
too big and way too much money and the
reward is big but the risk is Big so
starting out now probably find a local
rundown single there
um worst house best street do it up
figure it all out work out how to find a
refurb team get a good letting agent
because I think that's really important
because I'm not a landlord
I am a landlord but I don't see myself
as a landlord yeah landlord goes and
collects the rent landlord does the
inventories landlords does the repairs
landlords you know they get involved in
all the technicals I'm an investor yeah
and I think that's really different so
if you're starting out go and buy a
local single letter
2023 do I think there's going to be more
or less demand for residential housing
more because we're not building anywhere
near enough do I think the High Street
is going to get better or worse worse do
I think property prices are going to
rise or fall four so there's big
opportunities in 2023 I'd say If you
think house prices are going to fall and
you're buying houses and doing them up
and then they're dropping in price how
does that work well if you want to buy
it today sell it tomorrow it doesn't if
you want to buy whole die it doesn't
matter what you pay right if I pay 220
or 2
40. yeah because you know my trousers
aren't going to comment down any more
than 20 grand if I time it wrong are
they
um by the way the Market's already
turned in my area 15 down already so
let's say I buy now and it drops another
20 percent
like worst probably well that's still
that's 40 Grand on a 200 grand house but
in 12 years that'll be worth 400 Grand
and in another 12 Years it'll be worth
800 Grand and in another 15 years it'll
be worth 1.6 million so people who worry
about mistiming it and buying it at the
wrong time they're thinking too short
term
so you think now is a good time to buy
property well
the best time to buy property is when
you're ready
not in the market is ready when you're
ready do you need a house to live in
because you've got three kids and the
place that you're renting isn't very
nice and you need to build a home and
you want to settle somewhere and you've
been looking for three years
then the time for you to buy is now yeah
you don't wait three years in case the
market might drop to the right price and
still live in this rental that you don't
like so this is the thing A lot of
people are waiting for the right time to
buy the right time to buy is when you're
ready and I've been ready for 17 [__]
years and I will be ready for another 50
years I'm ready every day if the phone
rings now I'm ready
yeah and the way I hedge that I might
miss time it
is because I buy hold dye so the you
know you can make a bad investment in a
company or a stock
and it can go to zero you make a bad
investment in property it doubles and
doubles and doubles in 12 24 36 years so
as long as you hold it even rookie
mistakes which I've made they get ironed
out yeah
interesting what about if you're wanting
to get cash flow from a property if
you're buying properties now you know
interest rates are rising you're going
to have to
cater for the management the maintenance
you have to pay expensive letting agents
like Progressive
boom you're not left with very much
they generally speaking it's very very
small profits so if you're buying lots
of houses but they're not it's not
bringing in much cash flow what do you
do about that well you have to buy
cheaper
um I want to talk about interest rates
real quick because everyone's like three
percent nice really expensive money no
it's not
do you know the long-term interest rate
average five to six
so people have got so used to yeah 0.25
actually they should have been smart
realized the cash flow was really good
at that rate of interest and stashed
that yeah because actually three percent
is not expensive money it's still
relatively cheap money
um now what will happen my prediction is
that as if interest rates go up to five
or six people on variable rates their
mortgages are going to double and triple
in terms of their monthly payments a lot
of them aren't going to be able to
afford to keep that property they're
going to sell that property they need to
sell it fast and if you want to sell it
fast you have to sell it cheap so you
sell it cheap so it brings the market
down and then investors come in and pick
them up yeah so if rates go up
properties will just get cheaper if
lending gets harder properties will just
get cheaper it happened in 2008 you know
I saw it so if you think look you've got
to do your numbers like if you don't
know what that property will make before
you buy it that's your first rookie
mistake you've got to know what it's
going to make before you buy it and you
do the maths and it doesn't work well
then you offer cheaper
or you buy something that he's doing up
and you add value now look some people
know everything yeah I can get a buy to
let and I'll make 500 a month no you
won't you might make 75 pound a month
net net like you rightly pointed out
there are a lot of expenses that people
don't see
but every time you push the rent up most
of that
is profit because your expenses are
fairly fixed yeah
and then also you've got the capital
appreciation
now is that my favorite type of thing to
own hundreds of little houses no I like
to go to Big Red hotel from little green
houses but you've got to start somewhere
and importantly when you buy a little
single layer it only makes 50 pounds a
month net net well what else do you do
that makes 50 pounds a month net net
income not your job oh and then that
next year when you nudge your rent up 10
that's 125 pounds net net and then in
three years it's 250 pounds net now oh
and it's gone up 25 Grand in the last
year in value after the crash
and you know when you plant a seed you
don't come back the Nets ago they go
well where's my [__] trip but people
have that with buy to let they expect it
to make a Millions
but two three five ten twenty years it
gets big but there are creative ways as
you know there's
um rent to rents and multileps and other
ways if you're looking for cash flow I
buy hold die now the property that I've
got the 200 tenant one
you know that's a six figure a month
rent roll I'd have to get the exact
numbers off Mark but you know it's big
big numbers
so you can get more cash flow but you
have to do more work there's 200 tenants
in it yeah you know there's 99
apartments and you know I believe
everything is risk reward
how old are your kids
um 11.
and eight if you think about that one
yeah damn right if you teach me about
property yeah
I I've they've both had the hard hats
and the hive is on and they've been
taking tours around on my properties how
have you found as a trainer because I'm
a trainer and I look at the schooling
system and my kids are younger than your
kids and I'm thinking wondering what to
do about school
what have you decided and what's your
view on the schooling system [__]
hell Samuel I mean we're like
can of worms
so I I the honest answer is I've decided
what my wife wants
and what my wife wants is to put them in
the best
private school here my wife's quite
risk-averse
and my wife thinks that's the best thing
for her because she's risk-averse she
wouldn't necessarily entertain
homeschooling for example which I
probably would have entertained
um
and I don't think we've made a mistake
we've got the financial resources put
them in the best private school
um
that I that I could without it being you
know 100 miles away
it's a big part of me though that would
like to pull them out of the school
system really yeah why
because I think the school system
teaches you
to be a good employee
or a you know a good worker trades
or aura
it teaches you
to have a
skill
it doesn't teach you how to make money
and be an entrepreneur and be disruptive
and Innovative and
solve big problems in the world and
yeah so
I don't have any aspirations for my kids
to be anything other than what they want
to be
and if they wanted to be a doctor or
dentist or a lawyer go to the best
school go to the best college get the
best education yeah that being said
maybe with 3D printing and AI in 20
years even being a doctor will be
disrupted in a big way but
you know if I wanted to impose what my
will on my children which you partly
have to do as a dad
but you party have to be careful when
you do as a dad I've done it I want my
son to be world number one golfer he got
to work pretty much third best in the
world age six and we had to back off
because I was too intense with him and
it wasn't what he wanted to do and I was
living a bit of my failed youth through
him yeah so I've been there so I want my
kids to be what they want to be but if I
got the choice
they're going to be entrepreneurs
and the school system is not set up yeah
right for entrepreneurs not at all it's
the opposite
Robert Kiyosaki talks a lot about the
schooling system and of course Robert
Kiyosaki author of Rich Dad Poor Dad
massive inspiration to me
um I've had dinners with him I've seen
you trolling him a little bit on
Facebook
some of his posts and predictions and
you've been
I can't remember exactly what you said
but what's your thoughts on Robert
Kiyosaki um well I'm not a troll
okay um so number one
it's my profile and page and a troll is
obviously a fake profile all right
controlling's the wrong word I've seen
you slightly taking the Mickey out of
him
um I've definitely if I see something on
social media that I don't agree with
I'm happy to share my disagreement Dave
Ramsey
all debt is bad
no it's not
that
is a stupid thing to say yeah
because you and I
probably wouldn't have a single property
if it wasn't for good debt yeah so I'll
I'll [__] tell him straight that I
don't agree and that's wrong where do
you think where do you think he goes
wrong
because all all debt isn't bad no yes
okay
I can't remember anything I've said to
or against him that I think is wrong it
was about him predicting a crash well
he's been predicting a crash since 1921.
he asked doesn't it it's just you know
he is a bit of a grump and and he has
been and you know he predicts a crash
and then you know he's got his thing to
sell
based off that
um I mean I've been predicting a crash
since lockdown 2020 so maybe some people
could come and say the same thing about
me but it's happening
and there was a lot of [__] going on
Robert kiyosaki's been predicted a crash
since the last boom so I just think of
course he's going to be right in the end
yeah you've had a lot of time Samuel I
can predict the next three crashes in
the next 50 years of course I can just
say it every year for 50 years there's
gonna be a crash I'll be right in the
end you've had a lot of famous people on
your podcast you've interviewed Andrew
Tate you've interviewed Floyd Mayweather
many many very famous people who's been
your favorite guest would you say and
why so um my favorite guess in terms of
me being a fan
not famous people
I love rock my rock God is Stephen
Wilson no one knows who he is I love
Cricket unless you know Cricket you
don't know who Kevin Peterson is so I've
got my personal favorites I put I
interviewed them because that I like I
am their biggest fan and that's a cool
thing to do when you interview
your ultimate Heroes but my ultimate
heroes are quite diverse and they're not
necessarily in our space so tick them
off
I've interviewed 20 odd billionaires and
I always love interviewing a billionaire
because a lot of people I think I'm
fairly judge billionaires
think that they're you know a leech on
society when often they are the biggest
producer in society
but in terms of pound-for-pound best
value across I enjoyed it it was
disruptive it got loads of views you
know it created virality it was the
perfect time
Andrew type really yeah interesting I
mean Floyd Mayweather was great but it
didn't it was that you know I didn't get
Floyd Mayweather at the height of his
career was my advice helpful to you
about Andrew take because I know you
messaged me yeah well I am yeah I
messaged you and we had a lot of Ding
Dongs
um because I thought interviewing
someone so high profile of the moment
I I think it's always smart to get
advice from people who've been there and
you just interviewed him a couple of
weeks before yeah so I messaged you and
just said look you know you any any do's
and don'ts
um what was good what was bad and you um
was it helpful
um
yeah there was one thing you said and I
probably didn't take that advice enough
was that
um I I argue with him okay yeah yeah
yeah because I'm not really
you know you've just been on my show and
I know there's a little bit of you that
was apprehensive but we didn't really
argue I'm not really like really like
arguing I definitely I'm not
uh like I don't expose anyone it's not
my job I'll be challenging
if I really like it but you say look you
need to argue with him more because on
the algorithm I saw all the arguments we
had that was all there was yeah and then
and I had probably had a I did a bit on
property because I think you and I think
similar and he thinks different on
property and had a bit of an argument
there at the end he asked me for a bit
of feedback and I said to him well you
know if I was doing this interview again
what one thing would you do differently
and he said argue with me more oh wow
yeah so I should have argued with him
more
um Andrew Tate talks a lot about taxes
about how rich people don't pay tax
um that's not true by the way well
that's what I want to ask you about it
Andrew talks about Robert Kiyosaki says
that as well it's not [__] true so so
is it not true is it that you're just
not using the same loopholes
well the first thing you have to do is
Define tax
because rich people in the UK pay
millions in vat I mean you see your vat
bill go every quarter I mean every time
my vat bill goes out million I'm on [__]
so I pay millions in vat Corporation
taxes 25 income tax is 45 you've got
national insurance which is now nearly
10 and you pay it for the employee e and
the employee pays it and the employer
pays it there's business rates
I'm [__] paying two-thirds of
everything I own earn
and buy in tax
here's the problem I'm rich I'm not
super rich
so super rich what they do is they
circumnavigate corporation tax
and then what they do is they
find ways of avoiding drawing
income whether it's through
shares
or other means so they are
circumnavigating
some not all Corp tax
and some not all income tax
but they still pay the v80 still pay the
National Insurance still pay the still
employed the thousands of people and all
the tax that that generates yada yada so
it's absolutely false to say rich people
don't pay tax
it's not true rich people the Richer you
are the more power you have to get your
corporation and your income tax down
but that's just two of a lot of taxes
um I actually think that it shouldn't be
taxed more I think the rich should be
taxed less I think the super rich should
be taxed more like imagine if the big
companies like Amazon and Google let's
say they're paying two percent Corp
instead of
19 going up to 25. imagine if they just
paid five percent Corp
that's probably a hundred billion to a
trillion all of a sudden flooded into
the economy is that not the [__] most
obvious solution to the problem so the
problem is the media or whoever have
created this narrative or the Richland
pay tax
okay you're rich
sure you pay a lot of tax you're not
super rich
and even with the good lawyers that we
might be able to have we don't you know
we can't set up a company in Ireland we
don't know how to do what Google and
Amazon do
so I can't remember the question but I'm
passionate about it well do you not
think that what you're saying when
you're saying it or what should happen
is the super rich should just pay more
tax no no not more than the fair amount
a little bit more than they are yeah
you should be paying less and I should
be paying less why should I who employs
144 people in this office and develop
[__] hundreds of units in the center
of my city and made my city like I sent
you the video didn't I have my
properties the why the grade they look
[__] nice that one on the edge
poundland that was a dump
and we've made the gate we have one of
the two Gateway buildings in the city
and we made that look beautiful so we're
housing a more than a thousand people in
the city were developing these
properties to to look really nice and
I'm getting absolutely hammered in tax
paying two-thirds of what I earn and
spending tax why I should be paying less
so I can employ more people and do more
deals and turn the city around even more
you should be paying less a millionaire
should be paid that's what
entrepreneurship no I don't and I'm
making the assumption that you don't pay
zero percent no don't be zero percent
tax but I think that so do you think
Andrew Tay is lying then when he says
about paying well what does he say tell
me what he says he says rich people
don't pay tax
um well that that is
I don't think he's lying I just don't
think it's technically accurate
and you have to Define rich people as
well because
in some areas I mean 70 grand a year is
Rich I got paid 850 000 pounds in last
month
so that's not rich to me
um
so depends on how you define rich
and how you Define tax up
I think it's actually important to be
quite technical here because what I
think is it sounds great on social media
that rich pain attacks and there the
more money you have the more you can
invest in good lawyers and good tax
advisors and if you made that money
that's your prerogative
um but they generate Millions
Millions think of all the council tax
that's generated from the properties
that you own yeah oh yeah think of all
the business rates passionately though
rich people pay a lot less tax don't
they if you're I bet you proportionately
pay a lot less tax well actually then
your employees do it's not rich versus
poor this is where people get it wrong
it's employed versus entrepreneur
that's the difference people people love
to go oh the rich this that the other
they have no [__] clue yeah
um and people love to say that the poor
are you know the the hurt and the
affected I've spent 17 years of my life
showing people that there's another way
and that way is to be an entrepreneur
and it's not
that
the poor pay more and the rich pay less
the rich pay nearly all the tax
the argument of all but the percentages
is not relevant because if you pay 50 of
12 pounds 60 in tax and I paid 10 of a
billion I pay more tax so this
percentage
I might have a lifestyle implication but
in terms of who generates the money for
the economy it's who pays the most
um the real issue is being employed
if you can get out of being employed by
being an entrepreneur all of a sudden
you pay tax last not first yeah this
expenses
and allowances and write-offs that you
get
as an entrepreneur or self-employed that
you don't get as being employed so the
rhetoric actually should be and this
wouldn't be good for media but the
rhetoric should be
the employed pay lots of tax and I broke
and the self-import employed pay less
tax
so but anyone can be self-employed
the government don't stop you
yeah in fact I mean I [__] a bit about
the government from time to time on the
things they've done wrong but there's
some good good tax breaks being an
entrepreneur which I'm grateful for what
drives you in your business because you
you know you have a lot of energy you've
got a lot of different businesses going
on what is it that you could presumably
retire and just live happily ever after
on a beach with the family what is it
that keeps getting you up in the morning
well I hate to see and I hate the sand
and I hate the Sun so that's that's that
fact that dream that everyone else has
got I don't like don't like don't I
don't like being bored I don't like
sitting on the Sun Lounge I don't like
having nothing to do I've tried
retirement [__] loads of times just a
running joke in my company in in our
industry of how many times I've retired
so what drives me number one is I want
to be valuable and important I want to
make a difference in a lot of people's
lives I want to be useful when I was the
fattest kid in my year at school age 11
to 13. I felt useless felt pushed aside
I felt No One Like Me respected me and
noticed me and when I lost all the
weight because I had so much pain of
that I just lost all the weight one
summer I was three stone in you know the
summer holidays and all of a sudden I
was skinny and girls started to notice
me and the people didn't push me away
but all those feelings never left me now
you know a lot of personal development
courses and a lot of therapy later I've
accepted that that's who I am and that's
part of me and it doesn't make me
useless but that's the whole that was
created
so everything I do the 18 books I've
written and you know the personal brand
and the property training is just
just want to be noticed and respected
and valuable and useful and make a
difference
and I'm one of the few people that
openly says I love money and I'm like
material things I've seen you say well
don't buy nice clothes don't have nice
cars
I'll buy expensive clothes and expensive
cars and expensive watches and take my
wife an expensive holidays and I buy my
kids expensive Lego
and I really like it I think what you've
seen me say is
um I mean don't get me wrong I have an
expensive car I I spend money on things
that I actually want to enjoy myself as
opposed to just to show off yeah so I
prefer my Range Rover that massages me
and as a fridge in it it drives nicer
than a Ferrari that's just gonna bang on
the speed bumps yeah
um well yeah I think we should all spend
money on the things that make us happy
but you shouldn't let Society tell you
what makes you happy you should find out
for yourself I bought my childhood dream
1987 Ferrari Testarossa
that's not just a Ferrari that I bought
that's my childhood dream manifested in
the most beautiful looking car that's
not materialism
that's like the energy and the
inspiration and the struggle over the
years it's all sat in that car which
mostly sits in the garage because it
[__] drives like a tractor
why would you not enjoy that like I love
Patek Philippe I love beautiful watches
who wants to go on a [__] holiday you
know and you want to go to nice places
live in luxury we all have equal light
to enjoy luxury what would you say the
best
um tips are on marketing because I think
you're a great marketer and you run
courses I believe on marketing and
social media I think marketing is an
important aspect to business give me
some top tips on marketing well the
single most important function of
business is marketing
marketing generates leads sales converts
leads into money
we can't do any selling if you haven't
got any leads so people get into
business and they make loads of mistakes
because they spend too much time on the
product too much time on the operations
too much time on the web design and not
enough time on marketing so what
marketing is if you imagine a shop Gucci
well once you're in the shop you know
you've got loads of nice clothes and
you've got the the the sales person
who's good at up selling you I wore a
Tom Ford suit to my wedding and I went
in for a suit and I came out with half
the shop you know he did a bloody good
job on me but I had to go in the shop
marketing is getting people in the shop
that's the most important thing so some
tips on marketing
um well at the moment you've got to be
noisy
you know back in the day you could be
the best it was all you know a lot a lot
of competition was on quality
but now quality is great but it's going
to take a long time whereas if you can
be noticed you know some some good
marketers say that
attention is the greatest currency
so how can you be seen if you can't be
seen you can't sell what you've got so
tip one is you've got to get seen
whether that is through Relentless and
consistency of
posting on social media and going to
networking events and being in your
industry trade
or a bit of viral hacking and
doing some
fun interesting
Billboards in Peterborough dressing up
at events challenging me to boxing
matches these kind of things get
attention
and without attention you don't have
anything else and there's the age-old
Ada of attention interest desire action
most people fail at attention and
there's a few big ones
you know our mutual friend Grant Cardone
is absolutely brilliant at attention I
mean on Twitter he's getting attention
everywhere and everything and vaccine
lockdown Twitter files Biden you name it
whatever's going on he's going to get
attention on it yeah
so attention is the big thing now of
course you've got to deliver now it used
to be under promise
over deliver now I think it's got to be
over promise over deliver
um and then
have a really good way
that it's easy for people to do business
with you and to refer people to you
because you could get a client
and then that stops
but if you've got a good referral
campaign and system
and you know your customers and fans
become evangelists of you and going
talk about you everywhere then you can
spread so you've got this core community
of clients so you can
build your business on but to scale it
without spending 300 Grand a month on
ads like I sometimes do
you've got to get them as major
evangelists of you they like Andrew Tay
I mean the people I mean I know Andrew
Tate's Community I know a lot of them
and they would die for him
and they they cannot hear anything but I
mean he could get convicted of 922
crimes and they'll still love him and
they spread the message out wide
disruptive entrepreneur who do you think
is more disruptive out of me and you
I think you're louder
I think
you're good at getting attention
I've been creative over the years
I think in the training industry there's
a lot of things that happen now because
of us deal packaging no one knew about
that until we sort of scaled that up
similar with service accommodation you
build podcast agency in the studio and
all this stuff in there just stuff the
back of
jumping on
content
it's a hard one to answer
I'd probably have to say superficially
you and in depth for me
what do you think about property tribes
right okay so property tribes is
probably one of the biggest landlord
forums in the UK I think yeah and um I
know the owners
I'm one owner
Nick
I think he's pretty solid guy get on
with him quite well pretty balanced and
reasonable
um
but it is
it's the place where the disgruntled
pissed off landlords go
to [__] and moan not there's plenty of
other landlords that don't do that
but if there's a little community
like you know bees to honey we're all
the disgruntled landlords go it's there
and generally when people [__] and moan
about others is because they're pissed
off with themselves so disgruntled
landlords sees someone like you running
courses making loads of money out of it
and they [__] hate you and get [__]
up with you but if they were a happy
landlord they wouldn't give a [__] what
you're doing but they're a disgruntled
landlord they've got three tenants three
properties have been doing it 22 years
that they can't make it work they're too
Hands-On no no no no no no no
um
so I think there's some useful
information in there I think they spend
a lot of it's more for landlords local
landlords Small Time landlords
um and you know for a while for a few
years
I think it was they were too free and
open with their criticism of big
landlords big developers and people who
run property courses which you know
we've regularly been the biggest so
we've regularly been the target of that
um and then it would just Veer into a
free-for-all of defamation
and then you came along and sued them
all and things changed yeah so that's
what I think well you said you know the
owners who are the owners well
um Nick Tad and now you correct so what
did you think when you when I bought 35
of property tribes
honestly I [__] chuckled
I had a little tickle a little chuckle
because
property tribes is look they don't do
all things bad let me give you some
balance mate don't disc proper tribes
like that's my baby well no you want me
to be honest don't you yeah that's my
business yeah but you want me to be
honest I'll be honest all right so
you know property tribes would have
saved some people for some dodgy deals
or lending money or whatever there's
plenty of people in this industry who
[__] nicked money and lost money and
traded badly and property tribes would
have exposed some of those but they just
it's just like they chucked the baby out
with the bath water and they just slap
that across everyone without any proper
ironically they're the place of due
diligence and research yet they don't do
due diligence and research themselves on
the people that they're criticizing so
the problem is they save a few but they
steal the dreams of the many
and I made mistakes in other things in
my life and I made no money I made
mistakes in property and I made a lot of
money and you know name me a person with
a lot of properties who's broke and
failed no one everyone knows that UK the
big big people have got property yeah
um so in that regard it it but the
problem is what it what it is really is
just it's just a small time this be a
landlord unless be [__] off with
everyone else kind of community for the
most part but
hopefully that'll change now though well
would you agree with me on what I said
about that uh yeah oh yeah I think
there's a it's a negative toxic place so
how are you going to change it then so
you bought 35 the reason I thought it
was I thought it was a disruptive play
and the reason I thought that was
because
um you know a good way to
gain control and have a a good move in
chess with people you're in legal fights
with is to bipart their company so I
thought it was a nice chess move yeah
check why not check mate but check I'll
explain in when you interviewed me about
my reasoning behind it
um you know for sure what would you say
though you're right that property tribes
that they do at times protect people
from the bad you know the bad trainers
the bads what would you say due
diligence should be done on a property
training company before or or what do
you think qualifies someone to be able
to set up as a property trainer
right so this is where I chuckle it when
they talk about due diligence because
it's clear they don't know anything
about business
because you know they might say things
like go on company's house
that tells you virtually nothing I mean
a public a PLC you there's a lot more
information but you know a small
Enterprise
you know the way that they file accounts
and how out of date they are
um
it doesn't tell you anything or it tells
you something three years late
so they're like go on company's house
and they immediately judge you on
company's house so do you know how many
companies I own
no no but you might think I'll I'll
check on companies as Progressive
property that's actually not the name of
my company
and then there's lots of other companies
I own how would you ever find them you
might you might find some Associated
companies you can often find that but
how how can you find out everything
that's going on in all those different
companies and entities and then
oh go on land region find all the
properties they own but there might be
options
they might have a a property company
with a lot of those
that I don't really have that many
properties in my personal name anymore
they're all in various property
companies various
so there's no [__] way they could
find all of that but what they'll find
is one company
with accounts that are from two years
ago and they'll make a judgment so
company's house is a part of the story
now if you go on company's house and
there's been 18 companies that have
started unfolded in the last two years
and blah blah blah then it's a bit like
looking at a CV when someone's at a job
every year yeah so company's house is a
very small part of your research right
move and property ownership is a very
small part of your research Googling and
looking online is a small part of your
research what you've got to do is you've
got to find about
let's say 12 different sources what's
their overall reputation
what's the overall results
of their clients how long have they
overall been doing it what's
Google say what does company house say
well does land reg say and you add all
these things up and then you get a
flavor yeah so that's really helpful
what do you think qualifies someone then
so how long do you think you need to
have been in property
how successful do you need to be you
mentioned before off camera about how
people might you know sell two or three
have two or three flips and then
suddenly they get a flipping course and
it's like well or they have a lease
option course but they've never even
seen a lease option to the end yeah you
know they've got one lease option
agreement and they then run a course on
it how successful do you think you need
to be in property I mean I was a
millionaire before I before I started
doing any courses
um you had a lot of success as well
what's the line before when you it's
like yes this person's now ready
yeah that's difficult because it's an
unregulated industry which has its
upsides and downsides you wouldn't want
being a doctor or a lawyer to be
unregulated that's highly regulated and
it needs to be but I can know nothing
walking to an estate agent and I can
offer 10 over market value and I can buy
a house and then I can rent it to a
tenant and I'm a landlord and I'm an
investor and that the downside of that
is not enough barriers to entry the
upside of that is any of us can buy
property so you you've got to weigh that
up so for me I reckon we've done about
70 deals we didn't own them all traded
package some but
but really when you lay your head down
on the pillow at night
do you feel experienced and credible
enough
to put the faith of other people in you
and do you really believe that with
proof and volition you can deliver on
what you're teaching to them
because there is no regulation if that's
the measure
but someone in property tribes might be
say you need to have done it 12 years
but you could buy I know people have
been doing property 12 years they bought
four properties I bought 20 in my first
year so I don't think you can say amount
of time that doesn't mean [__]
you could say amount of deals maybe but
you've got to look inside yourself
there's things I feel super qualified to
talk about and there's things that I
don't and I don't teach what I don't
feel qualified
do you think the property training
industry should be regulated well
regulation again is nuanced
certain bits are regulated right I was
gonna I was actually going to say that
it is regulated yeah people say oh it's
unregulated it's like no it's I think
that it's quite the emulated well the
FCA will be on your back if you say
certain things when you ask for money
for example so it's nothing is fully
unregulated it's not and also the
contracts and insurances there's a lot
of when I see people setting up training
getting a mortgage then that's that's
regulated being your property trainer is
quite regular people sometimes just
don't realize what they need to do what
they need to put in place yeah so it
already is
semi-regulated I guess here's the
probably the line that's blurred what
promises can you make
now America there's a lot more
disclaimers because you know you get
sued for blinking at someone
so they have to have a lot more
disclaimers and
probably
over the years
certain industries which might be deemed
in the negative as get rich quick may
have been controlled and what happens is
that usually comes over to the UK
a few years later so can you say
everyone will be a millionaire if you do
my course no and you shouldn't say that
and you shouldn't be able to say that
but um you could build a property
portfolio that could replace your
pension
and my training course will help you on
that journey and give you strategies and
tactics
to be a property investor that's all
completely true I should be able to say
that but I shouldn't be able to make
Wild
claims and guarantees without backing up
with proof
have you had a lot of haters
yeah I have a lot of haters because I
have 10 times more followers and fans so
if I get one out of 10 haters I think
I've done all right it's not a bad
percentage I've got millions of
followers so that's a lot of haters I
mean you could fill
Manchester United football stadium with
my Hayes how do you deal with that how
do you deal with getting haters and
people commenting online
how many of them know me
0.1 percent
how many of them have just hated a post
and then got on with their life and
probably forgot they even did it
probably a lot over the years when I've
studied rich and successful people
because I want to be rich and successful
that there's a few common things the one
big common thing is they've transcended
a certain level of judgment they
understand that like for example why
should you allow to be rich and not have
any critics that's not balanced and in
fact critics which is different from
haters but critics keep you accountable
like there's some people in property
tribes I've learned from
and over the years it's like yeah yeah
you're right about that I just need to
be technical with what I say and
so you learn from critics I like having
critics I mean you know one's ego or
one's emotion sometimes doesn't like it
yeah but once that transcends and you
know you don't get
there's no illusion of that you know
okay well usually haters are having a
bad day or haters just want to Nick
business of you or haters whatever
whatever there's something going on in
their life they don't know me so it
doesn't make any difference to me and
actually they're good for virality more
comments
I understand I'm not an expert on the
algorithms they'll never tell you it all
but I understand that sub threads are
really good for algorithms so let's say
you post and I
comment and then there's a big
discussion in under my comment and I
start arguing with that's good for the
engagement and the reach of yours so I
should love all my haters they're
helping me go viral
so you're how much would you sell your
property company to me right now
going to buy your whole property company
well the first thing I'd want to know is
what are you going to do with it what
are your motives
because you know if you want to slice
and dice it and
run it into the ground you could offer
me 100 million
I'll tell you to get in your Range Rover
and [__] off
but enjoy the massage yeah
um but if I was ready to sell and I had
something else to do and you offered me
Fair money
and you had a good plan
to continue what we'd built
why would I not consider that
I mean my walk away money here is
I mean I'm not even entertaining it
if it's not
50 million
I'm not I'm not even gonna just there's
no conversation to even start
um I know what my Revenue my profit is
and the multipliers are and then there's
other assets that we have
also have buildings and things that
makes it a bit more complicated so you
you ain't getting in for less than that
um but
like
I think we should always be open to
discussion of things yeah so why would
do you plan to sell your training
company one day
I don't necessarily 100 plan not to
I mean would I sell
51 percent
to a brutal
um
fund
who wanted to bring in some Hatchet
FD
and cut my company company to bits no
offer me a hundred million no for the
right price with the right motivation
you'd consider it yeah if I had
something to do afterwards that was
meaningful like I could maybe do my
podcast on YouTube full time I mean I've
got rob.team nearly 10 000 members in my
membership membership site we've got an
agency in there that produces YouTube
and podcasts for people if I've got to
have something to do Samuel yeah I can't
do nothing
I'd rather have 25 million in a
meaningful Mission than 100 million and
nothing to do that's that's me so it's
not something useful to do and I'm not
non-competed out of that and it's to the
right person who knows maybe well Rob
thanks so much for coming on the show
it's been a pleasure thank you very much
appreciate you man
[Music]
welcome to the eviction
2022.
over the next few weeks you're going to
have a series of very intense property
investment challenges and the winner is
going to be given 20 000 pounds cash
prize to help kick-start your property
investment Journey
the help of various mentors that are
going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges all decide who stays
and who gets evicted
because you needed to be spoon fed wow
just don't lie to me don't call me a
liar I'm not gonna lie down and take it
can I have a break
isn't it
you're evicted